.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Parachute. C'est une desmarqus
emblématiques des années 80.
Et c'est à Montréal que
Parachute a pris son envol.
Le musée McCord consacre une
exposition à cette griffe qui
était en parfaite adéquation
avec son époque.
STÉPHANE LEDUC, commissaire
expo. "Parachute" Musée McCord
- Il y avait un renouveau parcet
punk qui était un mouvement
un peu révolutionnaire,
et là, le New Wave arrive qui
est un mouvement intéressant
au niveau musical parce qu'il a
plus de légèreté. C'était
une mode qui permettait
de s'exprimer, de sortir des
sentiers battus et d'apporter
des idées nouvelles.
- De Michael Jackson à Madonna
en passant par Peter Gabriel
et Duran Duran, les stars
se l'arrachaient.
ALEXIS WALKER commissaire expo
Costume, mode, Musée McCord
- C'est vraiment lié à New York
et surtout l'influence de MTV
à l'époque. Tout à coup, t'as
besoinbesoinbesoinbesoinbesoin r
avec la musique.
- Les designers Nicola Pelly
et Harry Parnass ont contribué,
avec Parachute, à redéfinir
la mode des années 80.
Magasiner chez Parachute était
une expérience. Leurs boutiques
étaient soigneusement aménagées
dans un style industriel
et minimaliste. De New York
à Tokyo, la griffe a connu
un succès planétaire entransforé
de la mode de rue, en une marque
sophistiquée, internationale
et haut de gamme.
L'exposition "Parachute :
mode subversive des années 80",
permet de revivre les heures de
gloire de Parachute à travers
des croquis, des photos de
l'époque et une soixantaine
d'ensembles.
- Parachute, pour moi, ils ont
vraiment travaillé dans
le processus postmoderne.
Ils ont combiné les références
des vêtements militaires,des vê,
des vêtements du Japon
traditionnels du Japon, avec
un côté endrogyne, un petit peu
rebel et aussi l
sur la silhouette, ce lien
avec l'architecture.
- La marque phare des années 80
n'a pas survécu à la décennie.
La dernière boutique a fermé
en 1993.
L'exposition nous permet
de constater que la mode de
Parachute reste bien actuelle.
Et la cofondatrice, Nicola
Pelly, n'exclut pas qu'un jour
Parachute se déploie à nouveau.
Ici Nabi-Alexaner,
Radio-Canada, Mo